in Bali preparations are underway to
welcome some of the world's most
powerful leaders security is the top
priority for the host nation
the G20 is attended by heads of States
so we are doing simulations of any
possible threats like terrorism hostage
situations and any other extraordinary
event that is the duty of the Special
Forces
in the weeks leading up to the summit
elite soldiers have taken part in drills
including paratrooper training more than
18 000 military and police officers will
be stationed in nusadua the resort
District hosting the delegates 12
warships will be deployed and more than
a thousand Personnel will be on standby
for evacuations in case a natural
disaster occurs in terms of security we
are experienced we also pray that
nothing will happen but overall the
security from the police and military is
very good
Indonesia has experienced violent
attacks in the past biggest was the Bali
bombings 20 years ago it also sits on
the ring of fire making it prone to
natural disasters but authorities say
they have prepared for every scenario as
one of Asia's most popular tourism
destinations Bali is accustomed to
welcoming visitors from all over the
world but this will be the most high
profile event the island and Indonesia
has ever hosted
the tourism sector hit hard by covid-19
travel restrictions has started to
recover in recent months with tourist
arrivals and hotel bookings On The Rise
we do hope the G20 will be successfully
executed
if this is happen this is a big boost
for us in Bali
schools in the area will be closed for
the week to help reduce traffic around
the summit location
we are starting online learning again
because of G20 our Island our home will
be more well known because of the G20 so
our students understand and they are
proud
with the eyes of the world on their home
many believe this is a chance to
Showcase Bali a safe welcoming and ready
to host all kinds of visitors including
heads of state Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera Bali